est-ce que tu est favorable au divorce
bah si elle est mariée à jouer sinon le
divorce
tu sais des papiers de la paperasse
encore je suis pas favorable la
sexualité hors mariage la sexualité
il faut bien répéter avant le mariage de
toute façon mais quand on est marié
bah ça peut exister si certains ne
trouvent pas chez eux ce qu'ils auront
là ils vont chercher ailleurs
l'homosexualité c'est pas moi c'est
peut-être une solution je veux tu est
favorable à la peine de mort au nom il
ya tellement de gens qui sont pour
je ne peux être que contre tout en
précisant que je ne veux pas vous plaît
dans la catégorie des sadiques qui
préfèrent qui est un mec pourrissent
pendant 30 ans dans dans un cachot
quelconque bien que je peux mettre à la
place de certaines personnes dont
récemment ils ont eu leurs mômes de
violer tuer c'était un jeu bon
effectivement je ne sais pas ce que l'on
peut penser à ce moment là en plus
affiché un certain cynisme un certain
neil is me voir qu'est ce que tu as des
tabous tabou tabou tabou tabou des
tabous non non pas vraiment y a rien
avec quoi tu ne rigolerai pas c'est à
dire que la seule manière de justement
ne pas en rire c'est d'en rire parce que
je crois tu crois en dieu je préférerais
que ce soit lui qui croit en moi dieu
c'est un vaste mot 1
il faut croire en cours
tu crois que tu y crois pas à ce vaste
monde ah oui il faut y croire
enfin dieu ou peut-être s'est dit si je
sais pas quoi dire sur moi quelqu'un qui
nous surveillent je pense que tu es un
bon père j'ai une bonne paire mais un
bon père je sais pas et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu